thank you very much Madame's president
honourable members thank you so much for
this important debate answering the
question of Lithuania the Commission is
aware of a draft law of equal treatment
currently pending in the Lithuanian
Parliament and related amendments which
fail to extend a list of grounds for
prohibited discrimination not including
gender identity as such which might
result in transgender individuals having
no legal mechanism effectively securing
them from possible discrimination in a
variety of spheres such as education or
work we cannot comment on draft laws but
we are looking at this very closely
and we will act if there is a competence
to act
the Commission has during the last you
supported different actions and
initiatives in several member countries
to improve tolerance and social
acceptance of LGBTI persons there was a
conference suggest some some weeks ago
between the common with the Commission
and the Finnish presidency to take stock
of what has been done and what can be
done further as well exactly what will
be done will of course be for the next
Commission to define in this regard as
you know in the area of employment there
is a directive ribbiting discrimination
on grounds of sexual orientation and the
Commission proposed more than 10 years
ago to expand that scope covering also
other grounds of discrimination based on
sexual orientation in education in
Social Security is Social Protection and
access to and supply of goods and
services and you know very well that
negotiations has been going on for a
very long time in council but it has not
required had not received the required
unanimity yet honourable members this is
not an ideological discussion it is
about the rights of LGBTI people and the
obligation of Poland to respect and to
protect them as I said in my
introduction the Commission strongly
condemns the developments in Poland when
it comes to hate speech declaration on
so-called LGBTI free zones and the
attacks against LGBTI people especially
under the election campaign we will very
soon in a couple of days in fact
celebrate the tenth anniversary of the
Charter of Fundamental Rights and I
think it is very important to defend the
fundamental values of the EU and
unfortunately even ten years after we
are standing here today all Member
States have signed up to these values
and have signed up to respect them it is
a fundamental value to love whom you
want and to be respected for that and to
be who you want discrimination
intolerance and violence based on sexual
orientation or gender identity are
against these fundamental values and I
can assure you that the Commission in
the future and my friend and colleague
Commissioner ovah who has been very
engaged in these questions and who will
be incoming vice-president responsible
for the rule of law will continue to
engage and fight for LGBTI rights in
Poland and elsewhere and I count on your
support in that struggle thank you so
much
thank you very much Commissioner
Malmstrom and now we have concluded the
debate the vote will be taking place in
December
yeah meat aisle in sear - I didn't hear
any suomen mainland acetal estaba
sarahvani
committee on your kilo so much Tolman
pitesti laputan Airbus kiss tacos Kevin
Betty own paddocks and pyroxene Europe
and metallo ten yeah Sol Anatomy namu
stood at the pianist America via poo
have aria yes eNOS in court in QC
Mexico's cavalry unit void an acetic at
Milano Kovac into not register NT tapa
ties Acosta arrest Alma yeah bottom use
nautical tone yet is to tussle in season
Carlin